[Applaudissements]
bonjour à vous alors je vais faire un
pacte
et moi l'histoire que je
comptez c'est celle qu'on m'a demandé
d'expliquer lorsque est devenu évident
que l'avenir n'était pas simple voire
même il allait falloir changer tous
autant que nous sommes
la question que je vais poser et à
laquelle je vais essayer d'apporter une
réponse c'est celle de comment fait-on
pour changer échanges et si possible
durablement pas changé juste en
apparence pas faire semblant vraiment
changé par exemple face à la crise
écologique au sens global du terme
comment par exemple pour des étudiants
de l'ena en 2006 faire en sorte qu'il
comprenne qu'il y a des problèmes
techniques et qu'il faut aussi résoudre
les problèmes sociologiques le problème
sociologique numéro un c'est apparemment
l'opinion a évolué nous savons qu'il y a
un problème de crise écologique globale
mais les comportements e n'évolue pas ce
sera mon premier point deuxième point je
voudrais faire un petit détour avec la
sociologie et la psychosociologie sur la
question des attitudes pour ne pas en
rester à l'opinion ou le comportement va
prendre un peu de hauteur
et puis troisième point comment est-ce
qu'on change et là je vais vous proposer
une petite méthode premier point vous
êtes au courant
pas la peine de s'y attarder
l'environnement l'écologie c'est très
important
80 % des gens sondage récent mais depuis
les années soixante dix à peu près nous
sommes entre 75 et 85 % à considérer que
ce sujet est vraiment important voire
même qu'il nécessite que l'on change
très bien
disons que l'opinion a évolué et
pourquoi
d'abord parce que il y a plein de choses
qui nous ont fait évoluer des films home
de arthus bertrand
le syndrome du titanic nicolas hulot al
gore les séries télé bref l'imaginaire
sociétal met en scène quelque chose de
l'ordre d'un effondrement possible
et ces derniers mois cela a pris encore
plus d'ampleur la coop 21 bien sûr mais
aussi tout un tas d'autres éléments
donc la société a changé en termes
d'opinion mais pour autant on sait qu'
il y à une crise grave qui s'amène que
les températures explose que les
consommations de gaz à effet de serre
explose que la population explose et
vous voyez là tout en haut à gauche
on continue à acheter de plus en plus de
suv
nous avons donc un problème ce problème
c'est que les gens se disent prêts à
changer et pense même que c'est la seule
solution à plus de 3 cadres que le
progrès technique certes à un intérêt
mais il ne permettra pas d'éviter le
problème
donc nous savons nous savons et pourtant
nous restons comme indécis nous ne
savons pas comment faire exactement ce
vaste changement
voilà un schéma qui résume bien au
milieu l'individu qui doit à changer qui
doit évoluer au dessus de lui toutes les
méthodes psychologique tout ce qu'on
peut inventer le signal prix et plein de
méthodes psychologique pour vous faire
bouger dans votre tête
mais ça vous fait pas bouger dans votre
quotidien sur la droite là bas vous
voyez plutôt les groupes d'appartenance
les groupes auxquels vous appartenez
votre famille vos amis les clubs tout un
tas de choses
eux aussi peuvent vous aider à changer
ça ce sont des méthodes en bas vous
voyez la société oui elle aussi la
société va vous aider à changer avec des
normes des règles des lois mais pour
autant et on l'a vu récemment quand on
fait bouger les choses en terme de
société avec des primes ou
impôts et bien il y à un recul il ya
tout un tas de gens qui n'acceptent pas
ce changement là et enfin à gauche bien
sûr pour vous aider à changer on va vous
trouver des solutions techniques
bref ce rapport qui avaient été publiées
en 2016 explique toutes les méthodes
existantes pour vous aider à changer
et pourtant ça ne marche pas il y a
environ 75% d'entre nous qui disent
qu'il faut changer et réellement il y a
environ 15% d'entre nous qui change ce
qui nous fait un petit problème de
l'ordre de 60% de la population qui ne
comprennent pas comment on fait pour
changer d'abord qui ne comprennent pas
le monde qui arrive et qui ne
comprennent pas comment ils pourraient
changer
je vous ai mis cette petite image pour
bien de vous compreniez l'état dans
lequel nous sommes nous comprenons que
les lignes sont des droites et qu'elles
sont parallèles nous le savons mais nous
n'arrivons plus à le voir cette
différence de perception ce problème de
perception est aussi un problème social
nous avons du mal à remettre les carrés
au bon endroit quand l'écart était
aligné tout allait bien
tout était bien droit à partir du moment
où l'écart et bouge alors plus rien 20
tout s'effondre notre représentation
collective et donc notre imaginaire
social et donc nos actions dans ce monde
imaginez qu'un de ces carrés s'appelle
le progrès on ne sait plus très bien si
c'est bien ou mal le progrès
imaginez qu'un autre s'appelle le
confort pareil quel confort et est ce
que le confort n'implique pas
éventuellement de tuer des animaux pour
votre confort est ce qu ils ne polluent
pas le confort est ce que le progrès le
confort l'innovation l'intelligence ne
sont pas des mots des concepts qui ont
tellement bougé on n'arrive plus très
bien savoir ce qui est bon et ce qui est
bien en cette société et du coup nous
restons les uns et les autres bloqués je
le disais 60% d'entre nous sont victimes
de ce qu'on va appeler une dissonance
cognitive
cette dissonance cognitive c'est est ce
que vous voulez le changement tout le
monde lève la main ou en tout cas 75%
qui est prêt à changer
et là plus personne ou presque ne lève
la main dissonance cognitive ça veut
dire qu'on aimerait bien faire quelque
chose mais qu'on n'y arrive pas et donc
nous sommes collectivement un peu malade
d'une maladie sociale qui peut toucher
les individus et aussi les groupes
d'humains et les sociétés et nous sommes
dans des sociétés qui disent il faudrait
et qu'il n'y arrive pas alors je
voudrais vous proposer une petite un
petit bout de solutions nous avons une
opinion qui dit il faudrait nous avons
un comportement qui dit j'y arrive pas
passons aux attitudes
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une attitude une
attitude est là pour le coup la
psychosociologie a étudié les gens en
laboratoire pour voir ce qu'ils font
vraiment et pas seulement ce qu'il
raconte
ou seulement ce qu'ils font mais
l'adéquation entre les deux et nous
voyons bien que nous avons des attitudes
qui ne sont pas en cohérence avec nos
opinions et même parfois avec nos
comportements vous voyez tout en bas à
gauche celle influence sociale c'est
celle que nous subissons chacun d'entre
nous pour nous forger des opinions nous
pensons telle ou telle chose bien ou mal
que telle ou telle chose est bonne ou
non principalement parce que nous sommes
influencés par notre milieu social nos
amis notre famille etc
ça nous forge des opinions individuelles
mais qui viennent toujours du collectif
ses opinions vont entraîner des
comportements
mais parfois ces comportements sont
obligatoires
le code de la route le fait que vous
soyez un psy et moi debout c'est les
conventions que nous avons entre nous
vous ne les avez pas forcément choisi
ces comportements mais vous avez des
attitudes et c'est là que je voulais en
venir c'est plus important que les
comportements ou les opinions à mon avis
c'est le gros bloc au dessus et ses
attitudes sont certes modifiée par les
opinions que vous avez vous êtes plutôt
un électeur de gauche plutôt un électeur
de droite même si ça aussi ça bouge
beaucoup
vous êtes plutôt un consommateur de
viande plutôt pas vous êtes plutôt
végétarien c'est une attitude vous êtes
plutôt auto soliste
tout seul dans votre voiture c'est
plutôt une attitude ça veut pas dire que
vous prenez votre voiture simplement
vous avez une attitude à l'égard du
monde vous positionnez comme j'ai ma
voiture personne ne monte et je ne veux
pas lâcher ma voiture ou bien vous êtes
cycliste ou bien vous êtes engagés dans
je ne sais pas là des choses
extraordinaires au niveau international
ce sont plutôt des attitudes et les
opinions et les comportements plutôt
stable que vous conservez et que vous
pouvez modifier si on passe par les
attitudes alors ces attitudes sont elles
aussi vous le voyez à droite là bas il
ya une flèche modifié par les
comportements
en résumé on sait en laboratoire que
quand on met 100 personnes dans une
salle la moitié veut arrêter de fumer
l'autre moitié non on leur fait tous les
sens arrêter de fumer
les oblige on les lâche dans la nature
au bout de quelques jours on les reprend
deux semaines après on demande qui a
continué d'arrêter de fumer qui n'a pas
continué eh bien on a le même nombre de
gens qui ont recommencé chez ceux qui
voulaient arrêter chez ceux qui ne
voulaient pas donc je sais qu mais en
termes humaniste ce n'est pas
extraordinaire mais nous avons tendance
à être plus guidés par nos comportements
qui deviennent des attitudes que par
nous seule opinion sur le monde
pour changer changer ça veut dire que
vous devez changer de source de votre
influence de tout ce qui vous influence
alors ça veut dire que vous devez
changer les gens qui vous disent ou qui
vous démontre que ça c'est bien et ça
c'est moins bien sinon vous ne changez
pas sinon et celle influence sociale qui
nous l'expliquent ya trois grandes façon
d'influencer le reste du monde
la principale c'est l'autorité vous êtes
assis je suis debout c'est comme ça et
dans plein d'endroits le professeur et
de boules celui qui parle est debout et
puis il ya vos parents l'autorité il ya
l'état autorité l'école l'armée même si
toutes ces autorités s'effondre petit à
petit sociologiquement elle garde quand
même un peu d'importance dans l'influent
ce qu'elles ont sur votre attitude et
sur vos comportements deuxième type d'
influence le conformisme la publicité et
le fait que
vous faites comme tout le monde vous
avez appris à faire comme tout le monde
nous faisons tous comme cela
le conformisme évidemment c'est démontré
en laboratoire c'est aussi dans un
groupe vous savez que telle chose et
bleu et le groupe entier qui passent
devant vous dit que sévères et la
plupart des gens vont dire que c'est
vert parce que à quoi ça sert de d'aller
à l'encontre du groupe à laquelle quel
est l'objet c'est pas grave je vais être
comme tout le monde c'est pas un enjeu
sauf qu'à force de dire que c'est vert
alors que vous savez que ces bleus et
ceci est une expérience de laboratoire
et bien nous nous sommes habitués à dire
que les choses étaient vertes alors je
ne suis pas en train de dire que
l'individu doit absolument s'autonomiser
est peut-être en remettant en question
un certain nombre de ses conformismes
alors nous pourrions passer à d'autres
formes d' influence parce que sinon
l'autorité le conformisme c'est le statu
quo ni les gens qui ont l'autorité ni
ceux qui vous vendent des choses grâce
au conformisme ne vont vouloir que vous
changer quoi que ce soit au monde tel
qu'il est or il va falloir changer et
c'est ce que nous savons de tous débuts
face aux problèmes notamment de la crise
climatique
alors pour changer il ya deux grandes
façon la première c'est la déviance
il ya un problème c'est que vous payer
des amendes si vous êtes pris voir vous
allez en prison alors c'est la
manifestation c'est tout un tas de
choses ça a son utilité
sadi au monde il est possible de
remettre en question les influences
traditionnelles
mais la vraie façon de changer les
choses et elle a été découverte en
laboratoire encore une fois par un
psychologue social qui s'appelle serge
moscovici dans les années 70 a écrit un
livre qui s'appelle psychologie des
minorités actives et il démontre dans ce
livre qu'il a toujours existé une forme
d'évolution des sociétés c'est la
minorité agissante ou active au sein
d'une société il y à des groupes qui
pensent autrement que la majorité
ce sont donc des minorités ils peuvent
être nombreux ou très peu nombreux mais
ils peuvent en fonction de leur
comportement de leur attitude générale
quand ils sont dans la société
faire évoluer l'ensemble de la société
y'a plein de minorités à
dans nos sociétés il ya des gens qui ont
entre guillemets raison avant tout le
monde qui pensait par exemple que les
femmes devaient être également reconnu
que les hommes c'est le mouvement
féministe
les gay devait être non discriminés dans
la société c'est le mouvement gay des
années 60 70 et 80
tous ces mouvements sont nés avec des
minorités actives ont eu une attitude
générale consistante ont répété leur
message en permanence sont devenus des
mouvements sociaux qui ont pesé sur le
cours des choses et ont changé
l'ensemble de la société
c'est en gros une méthodologie du
changement social
c'est la seule forme d' influence
sociale qui fait évoluer les sociétés
les autres la font régréssés où la faune
stagner donc on sait qu' il faut
s'attaquer aux attitudes et plus
seulement à l'opinion et au comportement
on sait qu'il faut des minorités actives
et ses minorités actives en gros elles
vont permettre un changement
vous êtes au début tout seul comme dans
le film douze hommes en colère que vous
connaissez peut-être il est le seul dans
un jury de 12 personnes à penser que
l'accusé est innocent et au bout du film
petit à petit en démontrant en ayant une
attitude cohérente tout le long il
attire à lui un puis deux puis trois
autres jurés qui vont à la fin
considérer que en effet l'accusé est
innocent et bien d'une certaine façon
changer le monde et donc changé
soit ça passe par ce type de groupe est
donc là l'autre question qui est en
germe c'est à quel groupe
allez-vous vous rattachez si vous
souhaitez changer le monde
et bien pour ça il faut pour changer
trouver des groupes qui correspondent à
ce que vous voulez faire vous ne changez
jamais tout seul et vous ne changerez
pas la société vous changerez des
groupes qui seront de plus en plus des
minorités actives capable à un moment
donné d'emporter la décision dans
certains domaines c'est comme cela que
ça se passe en général dans la société
pour cela il ya bien sûr des étapes la
première je dirais que c'est qu'il faut
apprendre l'état
mon actuel comprendre surtout comment on
peut modifier les choses
c'est important parce que on ne sait pas
exactement quels sont les mécanismes par
exemple du réchauffement climatique la
plupart d'entre nous nous savons qu'il
ya un problème mais de là à savoir
comment ça se passe c'est autre chose
or pour être consistant une minorité
active efficace il faut savoir comment
ça se passe c'est donc le premier je
dirais le premier étape apprendre
comprendre partager avec d'autres qui
eux aussi doivent apprendre comprendre
de mieux en mieux et de plus en plus
deuxième étape il faut agir et surtout
expliquer pourquoi et comment on agit
c'est à dire bien sûr avoir des
comportements agir mais avoir aussi une
opinion et être capable d'influer sur
l'opinion d'autrui en lui expliquant
voilà pourquoi je prends mon vélo
voilà pourquoi je n'ai plus de voiture
voilà pourquoi je change de chaudières
et je mets des panneaux solaires
voilà pourquoi je décide de ne pas avoir
un troisième enfant
difficile parfois dans une société
surtout quand éventuellement vous avez
peur parce que vous n'êtes pas sur vous
même de votre place sociale que vous
avez besoin d'être réconforté ce qui est
une loi de la sociologie ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est le cas de tout le
monde
troisième point donc se rassurer si vous
voulez changer le monde et vous changez
et changer les choses vous devez trouver
les moyens d'être régulièrement rassurés
rassurer ça veut dire avoir une bonne
estime de vous même et faire en sorte
que les autres vous reconnaissent vous
voyez on revient sur ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
en fait vous construisez non plus une
dissonance cognitive
mais vous vous mettez en consonance
positive vous êtes aligné 10 certaines
personnes vous dit
enfin ce que vous faites et vous faites
ce que vous dites est ce que vous pensez
nécessaire pour cela vous devez avoir un
certain nombre de gens autour de vous
qui vous rassurent et vous ne devez pas
être seul en pointe
sabre au clair à aller vous faire tuer
immédiatement au début de la bataille
dont
de la stratégie de la réassurance de
l'estimé de soi des gens autour de vous
qui vous disent oui nous pouvons y
arriver
et enfin cette innovation sociale ce
changement que vous allez mettre en
oeuvre eh bien il va falloir le raconter
il va falloir en faire un nouvel
imaginaire
il va falloir en faire une norme sociale
nouvelle puisque toute société a besoin
de normes de règles de valeur et donc de
code comme le code de la route il va
falloir de nouveau code
le code du bien vivre ensemble et il va
falloir raconter l'histoire de tous ces
gens qui mènent une vie heureuse
agréable par temps de crise globale car
tant que nous n'aurons pas de récit
collectif d'imaginaire collectif
nous ne changerons pas la société car
nous ne pourrons pas leur donner à voir
ce que j'appellerais cette nouvelle
vision du monde cette nouvelle morale
non pas une morale qui dit voilà ce qui
est bon et voilà ce qui n'est pas bon la
morale des principes mais une morale des
conséquences et qui dirait je fais cela
parce que ça cela comme conséquence est
que je suis capable d'assumer les
conséquences de chacun de mes actes
voilà une nouvelle morale donc un nouvel
imaginaire donc de nouvelles valeurs
code normes
mais tout cela n'est pas simple à faire
car nous avons tous aujourd'hui très
peur nous sommes un peu subjugué par
l'ampleur de la tâche à accomplir
voilà pourquoi je voulais vous donner
quelques petits éléments pour démarrer
je remercie
[Applaudissements]